hey Vsauce Michael here attachment of
two people's lips kissing the average
person will spend about twenty thousand
one hundred and sixteen minutes of his
or her life kissing and the world record
for the longest continuous kiss is 58
hours 35 minutes and 58 seconds but why
do we kiss I mean if you think about it
it seems kind of weird right
I mean sure today kissing represents
peace respect passion love but when the
first two people in human history kissed
were they just kind of being gross well
let's begin with what we do know
kissing feels good and it's good for you
a passionate kiss burns about two to
three calories per minute and releases
epinephrine and norepinephrine into the
blood making your heart to pump faster
kissing more often is correlated with a
reduction of bad cholesterol and
perceived stress but these positive
effects didn't become widespread by
accident
why did brains and bodies that love
kissing become so common well a popular
story holds it that pac-man's shape was
inspired by the shape of a pizza with a
slice missing but Toru Iwatani the
creator of pac-man admitted that this
was only half true
Pacman's shape was also inspired by
rounding out the shape of the Japanese
character for mouth and its mouths and
pac-man's favorite activity eating which
together bring us closer to the heart of
the kiss evolutionary psychologists have
argued that what we know today as
kissing may have come from kiss feeding
the exchange of pre-chewed food from one
mouth to another mother birds are famous
for doing this and many primates are
frequently seen doing it as well not
that long ago it was common between
human mothers and their children in fact
before commercially
produced or DIY baby food instructions
were readily available it made a lot of
sense
recently Alicia Silverstone uploaded a
clip of herself mouth feeding her child
it seemed strange to some people but
even though yeah it exchanges saliva
which like any contact with an infant
can transfer pathogens healthy mothers
and healthy children can benefit from
the fact that kiss feeding provides
nutrients carbohydrates proteins iron
and zinc which are not always available
in breast milk plus an adult saliva can
help pre digest the food making vitamins
like b12 easier for the baby to absorb
so mouth to mouth attachment has a
history of intimacy trust and closeness
your saliva also carries information
about who you are your level of health
and mucous membranes in our mouths are
permeable to hormones like testosterone
making a kiss a way to taste tests of
potential mate a good kiss can be
biological evidence that your kisser
might be a good mate so as a strategy
for mate selection prehistoric people
who enjoyed kissing and did it more
often may have made better decisions
picked better mates reproduced more
successfully and eventually become the
norm giving us us people who love
kissing any infant could have seen those
benefits coming from a mile away even
though an infant's vision isn't that
great from birth to four months babies
can only focus on things about eight to
ten inches away from their face which
not surprisingly is about the distance
to their mothers face while
breastfeeding so faces especially those
looking right at us tend to be the very
first things in our lives we can focus
on and see clearly this might explain
why we are so good at detecting faces
humans are off the charts when it comes
to this in fact we tend to see faces
even
when there aren't any it's called
pareidolia because humans are so
cooperative it makes sense for us to be
good at recognizing faces and more
importantly detecting when someone is
looking directly at us and clearly
expressing when we are looking at
someone else a predator who lives by not
being seen needs a gaze that's less
obvious in fact research has shown that
ours surprisingly white scleras the area
that borders the iris isn't just an
accident but is a vital piece of human
eye morphology that makes it easier for
us to ascertain the direction of someone
else's gaze at a glance we also have
impressive gaze direction that works
inside our brains containing individual
neurons that fire when someone is
staring directly at us but that stop
firing if the gaze shifts just a degree
or two so yeah you can tell when you are
being watched
we humans are quite sensitive to it even
those of us with scopa phobia the fear
of being stared at but to be sure in
order for this to work the other
person's gaze must be within your line
of sight your field of vision that is
you can see them otherwise if the stare
is coming say from behind there is no
evidence that people can tell they are
being watched
the psychic staring effect falls within
the realm of pseudoscience no widely
accepted studies have ever found
evidence that it exists anecdotally
what's more likely is that the very act
of rubbernecking to see who's watching
causes people to look up and for your
gazes to attach but what about
attachment when no one is watching one
explanation for an infant's love
attachment to their mother doesn't
involve vision or staring but instead
food the idea is that we love our
mothers because as soon as we are born
they are a source of life-sustaining
nourishment but what if that nourishment
came not from a loving mother but from a
scary wire mother in the 1950s Harry
Harlow conducted a series of famous but
controversial experiments on monkeys at
the University of wisconsin-madison
Harlow's findings had substantial
implications on our understanding of
attachment but by today's standards his
work would largely be considered
unethical and one of his most famous
experiments Harlow separated young
monkeys from their mothers as soon as
they were born and stuck them in cages
with to fake mothers a soft one wrapped
in cloth that did nothing and a cold
mechanical mother made of wire that
nonetheless did provide food but despite
being a cupboard mother the young baby
monkeys didn't bond with her when Harlow
or his team scared the baby monkeys with
a strange contraption the monkeys ran
and cleaned not - their wire source of
life-sustaining nourishment but to the
soft cuddly and otherwise useless cloth
mother this suggested that warmth and
comfort was more important than food
when it came to nurturing attachment
Harlow also built a rejecting mother
which used a blast of pressurized air to
push baby monkeys away but instead of
finding another source of comfort these
monkeys clung even tighter at all times
than monkeys raised without rejecting
mothers and this is what blows my mind
the instinct for warmth and comfort in
newborn creatures is so strong it not
only resists attempts to frustrate it
but is paradoxically strengthened by it
Eckerd has tested this by using electric
shocks to discourage ducklings from
following the object they were imprinted
on but it only strengthened the behavior
and made them follow more closely than
ever before the fact that a wire mother
or a rejecting mother or receiving
electric shocks for attaching to your
mother would cause more attachment more
love more dependence seems like a
paradox but paradoxes can teach us as
Oscar Wilde put it a paradox is the
truth standing on its head to attract
attention and what gets our attention
here is the effect uncertainty can have
in 1955 AE Fisher conducted an
experiment on puppies his team separated
puppies into three groups members of the
first group were treated kindly every
time they approached a researcher
members of the second group were
punished for approaching the researchers
and puppies in the third group were
randomly treated kindly or punished they
grew up never knowing what to expect
their world was not a world of kindness
or punishment but rather one of
uncertainty what's really chilling is
that the study found that that group the
third group of puppies wound up being
the most attached to the researchers the
third group loved the researchers the
strongest and was the most dependent
upon them guy Mirchi called this the
polarity principle stress including the
mental stress of uncertainty is an
ingredient in attachment or love and
perhaps even manifestations of hatred
it's polar opposite somehow enhance love
uncertainty psychologically can lead to
some of the greatest feelings of
attachment
dependence good things and bad things in
our lives often seem random and out of
our control so it's no surprise that we
often react with blind love and
acceptance in the face of an unfair
existence because what else are we
supposed to do we are that third group
of puppies but investigating uncertainty
conquering it so as to make the best
decisions possible is advantageous so
over time life has favoured activities
that turn uncertainty into knowledge not
every person out there is the best mate
for you but if it didn't matter which
one you picked a kiss a taste test
wouldn't be necessary and it wouldn't
need to feel so good or bring us so much
pleasure so go out there and kiss
someone today and as always thanks for
watching
by the way tomorrow I am headed to the
European Space Agency's spaceport in
South America with euronews to watch a
rocket launch in real life do you have
any questions about space or space
travel today let me know in the comments
below and I will ask the experts your
questions